When volcanoes erupt in movies they do so
unexpectedly, and the eruption lasts as long
as the story needs it to last, but c'mon science,
what's it REALLY like?
I think my producer, Pam, had it right when
she said, "Volcanoes and dinosaurs are some
of the first things that get people excited
about science."
Volcanoes are incredible to witness, unless
you live in the path of one.
They can be destructive, dangerous, and deadly,
but they're a glimpse into the awesome power
of the planet beneath all our feet.
This week, unexpectedly, after 42 years of
silence, Calbuco volcano erupted in southern
Chile.
Residents had 15 minutes of warning, and 4000
people had to be evacuated as the volcano
spewed ash into
the sky.
No doubt, residents are asking how long can
this be expected to continue?!
According to research from Smithsonian Institution's
Global Volcanism Project, the median length
of a volcanic eruption is seven weeks, but
the length of volcanic eruptions throughout
scientific history is SUPER varied.
For example, the crater at the top of mount
Nyiragongo in the Democratic Republic of Congo
held a lava lake from to 1894 to 1977, but
when it "erupted" the lake drained in less
than an hour.
Conversely, the eruption of Stromboli volcano
off the coast of southern Italy has had low
level activity and occasional lava flows and
explosions since 450 BCE!!
Stromboli's been erupting for almost 2500
years -- most recently, with fairly large
explosions in August 2014.
The length and behavior of these long-term
volcanic eruptions can teach volcanologists
and geologists a TON about the ground beneath
our feet.
Mountains are created when tectonic plates
jam together, forcing rock upward, or when
magma from underneath the Earth's crust rises
through a weak spot, creating a volcano.
Magma is like a bubble in water, it's lighter
than the rock around it, and slowly rises
until it hits the surface.
As magma gets closer to the surface, gases
appear inside the magma -- like nitrogen bubbles
in a diver's blood.
When the magma and gas reach the surface,
they EXPLODE into the comparatively thin atmosphere
above the crust -- when that happens, it's
just like a soda that's been shook up.
Bubbles and explosions galore.
In 1983, magma under mount Kilauea in Hawaii
forced open a rift 6.4 kilometers (4 miles)
long!
When Kilauea cracked, lava fountains shot
1,500 feet (460m) into the air, with activity
continuing for 3 years before more cracks
spread the pressure under the volcano around
-- causing a low-level continuous eruption
which is still ongoing today, 32 years later!
Now, the eruption is used to learn more about
how lava behaves, and how magma flows beneath
the crust.
Scientists studying the Kilauea eruption -- and
the nearby new Pu'u 'O'o (pooh-OO-oh-oh) volcano
that formed over the crack -- have learned
more about the tectonic plates our planet's
continents ride on, how earthquakes happen,
and more about the toxic gases that escape
during volcanic activity.
They can also track the slight swelling of
the rock at the volcanoes surface to find
the magma pipes which feed the eruption -- sort
of like the volcanoes blood vessels.
Luckily, Chile's Calbuco isn't near any major
population centers, but when it erupted in
1895 it threw 30-cm bombs (1 foot) 8 km (5
miles) from the eruption site.
So, this isn't the big one for ol' Cal.
Chile has many hundreds of volcanoes, and
according to Penn State, this eruption will
continue until the magma melt beneath the
volcano has stabilized, and the pressurized
gas which has built up is released; but, honestly,
no one can tell exactly how long that will
be.
Volcanoes are so cool.
Seriously, who doesn't love watching these
things?
From a safe distance
of course.